okay so we're gonna play d4 now i
previously played the london
in this the england now who wants to
know how to refute the england
now i gotta i gotta show up to the party
here
[Music]
i've analyzed this now i'm gonna
actually play the best line against it
okay so he goes d6
sadly tutorial tutorial he doesn't play
queen e7 which is the testing move d6
just gives up a pawn
and basically what we want to do here is
trade on our own terms he takes d6
would allow him to develop his bishop
can we try to get
him to take on e5 so that we trade
queens
can we try to get him to be the one to
trade on our terms
we absolutely can we can do it by
developing a piece bishop to f4
i hope i'm not falling into a trap as
far as i remember this is the best move
if he takes on e5 we capture the q well
we trade queens
and because we're up a pawn and his
position is passive that's a trade
which is quite desirable for us we can
also take on d6 there's nothing wrong
with that
black doesn't have sufficient
compensation but i think this is the
safest move
and you can see that it's already put
put him in quite a bind
okay use this opportunity i'll get mater
styled drink some water
and pause the video at this point and if
you're
just along for the ride the moves and
you can't out talk tall
okay um what is the best well that's a
bit of a general question
oh the rosen trap is e takes d6 i'll
show the rosentrap that's actually quite
a beautiful trap
um let me take a sip of my water exactly
so he's kind of dumbfounded right now
black doesn't we just shut him down
completely
because okay so bishop g4 now of course
he takes d6 is much better because he's
going to end up with a backward pawn
here
uh whether he takes with the pawn
immediately or he takes with the bishop
he's going to end up with a bad pawn and
tad insult okay so he takes
now let's not forget about development
right uh just because
the opening has been successful doesn't
mean we should get arrogant
uh we should simply continue developing
our pieces which we are going to do with
knight c3
e4 is also possible but uh we can also
play e3
and i'm actually gonna do that
the reason i didn't play e4 is because
i'm a little bit concerned
that he might get his queen to e7 and
sort of x-ray me
okay great he's gone d5 but remember
he's down upon
just because he got his pawn to d5
doesn't really mean anything okay
let me think about this for a second so
what does he want what does my opponent
actually want to do where does he want
to develop his pieces
let's annoy him a little bit
well there's something that he wants
specifically
where does he want to go with this
bishop what is d5 accomplished
he wants to go bishop b4 and that
actually is a bit of a nasty pin because
he might ruin my queen side pawn
structure
right so let's actually play the move a3
let's annoy the heck out of him
this is not a move that i'm making
lightly i'm delaying my own development
but because he sacrificed upon and
because he isn't developed fully himself
i have decided i've made the judgment
call that i can get away with this and
i'm only two moves away
from deploying you know from finishing
my development
i could consider castling queen side but
that would sort of play into his hands
and i was gonna make the point uh which
i'll expand upon after the game
okay i'll talk about it after the game
and i'm gonna note it down here in my
notebook
okay so queen b6 is less dangerous than
it appears we can shut this down
several different ways uh one is to
develop our bishop but then he might go
a6
we can absolutely just go rogue b1
there's nothing wrong with that
okay that's a working working person's
kind of play
but there's absolutely nothing wrong
with that kind of play okay
uh we're just gonna defend the pawn uh x
gear 1313
and what you what you're going to see is
that
uh that's actually quite annoying to
deal with okay he castles
so now he wants to play d4
and uh that's a good idea but he's he's
gonna run out of fuel
well knight a4 he had queen a5 check
here
but we can set a vicious trap now here's
what i see
look at this queen very carefully look
at this queen very carefully
where can it go what are its two squares
it's only two squares
name them ladies and gentlemen c5 is one
and a5 is the other let's go before and
take them away from him
he might fit it worked like a charm
now mr where is your queen going
where exactly is that queen going to go
now nowhere it is trapped
let's go and i'll show you guys exactly
where i saw this before
yeah so d4 he blitzed out very quickly
but this is a typical idea as he's
thinking i'm not going to waste any of
your guys time i'm going to pull up that
classical game that classic game which
uh
which first taught me about let me see
if i can find it it's pologayevsky
against team on two very strong
grandmasters of the past
and this is one of the shortest games
ever played between two world class
grand masters
watch so um
well let me nanuka thank you let me
first make sure that he actually loses
because maybe he's waiting for me to
switch scenes
and uh he's lulling me to sleep and then
he's gonna make a move with two seconds
uh and don't worry i will actually go
over the game in detail yes okay so
i heard the sound that i like to hear
and now i'm going to switch scenes
now this is team one against polo yes
timon
was a legendary player i actually played
him in 2016.
uh he's he's very much still around he's
still good uh but he was basically one
of the top in the world in 1973 polo
gayevsky
was sort of a russian classic he was he
was the man
uh he was not 25 years old when he died
that's a chess-based glitch
uh but yeah he died young but he was one
of the strongest players in the world in
the 60s and 70s one of the strongest
players in the soviet union
uh and uh that's this is what he looked
like if i can move uh
what he looked like was if i can remove
my webcam
i'm trying to actually remove my webcam
well okay you can see part of him
anyways
i'm not gonna twiddle around with it
right now but he was very strong
so in this position private butters
think for the prime
t-mon plays knight to d5
whoa what kind of move is this black
can't take on d5 this is a very typical
move in the night or if timon is ripping
open the entire position okay it doesn't
matter right now
polugalyevsky goes queen to a5 he says
no no no i'm not
i'm not going to cooperate with you let
this knight just sit here
okay if you take on f6 no big deal i'm
just gonna take back
what does t-mon do here it's not exactly
the same thing that i did but it's very
very similar
all of a sudden white does
what he doesn't go b4 i know some people
are thinking that
because b4 relinquishes the a3 pawn i
called it
it goes knight to b3 very very very
quiet move
look at this queen if it goes to a4 the
queen gets forked
in fact even if it weren't for the fork
you could drop the i think this is
beautiful how
both knights come back from the d file
onto the third rank look at this
geometry
and then you finish off the queen with
a3 the queen is trapped and if queen
takes a2
then you still go knight c3 and the
queen is still trapped on a2
so polugalyevsky resigned a 16 move game
sorry 15 move game uh rarity for sure
but this is where i first learned about
uh the prevalence of this queens can
absolutely get trapped in the middle
game and some people aren't aware of
that
uh you have to become aware of that uh
queens can absolutely get trapped
in in the middle game you should be
actively looking for this stuff now back
to the game
so in the game in the action i think it
might be frozen no
so queen e7 is the sort of classical
move
and here you go bishop g5 that's
actually the strongest move according to
my analysis
now some of you will think wait a second
that is the trap
that's one of the england traps but this
is actually still the best move bishop
to d2
sorry queen takes b2 and now knight c3
uh there is a queen sacrifice here that
was sort of patented by amman
uh and and that queen sacrifice
basically goes let me
remember it bishop b4 rook b1 queen
takes c3 i won't delve into the theory
here i will be coming out with videos
about this stuff
but white is simply winning here uh this
is just not enough compensation for the
two pieces
it's just very very hard to play for
black thank you fellow teal for the
prime
anyways that's just very very quickly
how you should play against the england
uh what is the rosentrap the rosen trap
is bishop c5
knight c3 d6 can somebody
uh just assure me of this for a second
sorry let me pull up an instance of the
game here
so the rosen trap is where you go bishop
c5 knight c3
d6 and now you play no no sorry how does
it go exactly
it's bishop c5 but it's not knight c3
what is it i think it's like what does
white usually do here to allow this oh
it's bishop f4 or something
and then knight e7 if the knight is on
c3 it doesn't work and the idea is
obviously if it takes
and bishop takes f2 and queen takes d1
wins the queen
right uh so if you if you've gone into
this position
what's the what should i do here bishop
c5 without knight c6 sorry
so bishop c5 now d6
and 97 okay so i'm gonna verify this but
what should y do and in fact
we should do exactly the same thing that
we did in the game we should make sure
that we
trade this pawn on our own terms e3 is
passive it blocks in the bishop
we don't want to block in the bishop
where should we put the bishop
we should put it on not on e3 then he
takes it
should put it on f4 that's the best move
i believe in my estimation
because what we're trying to do we're
not we're still not threatening d takes
e7
but we're trying to get him to take with
a pawn in order to weaken his pawn much
like happened in the game
now we can play several different things
the simplest would be to go e3
then develop the bishop and simply
castle white is upon for no compensation
everything is good do not take on e7
ladies and gentlemen
because you lose your queen and bishop
takes f2 uh
i don't believe e3 is the best move here
uh e3 is also
fine and of course white is still up a
pawn for
very little compensation but i think
bishop f4 is slightly the
the more ambitious move so either is
good listen to eric i defer to eric on
this he's analyzed this i haven't
uh i haven't analyzed it formally so i
absolutely defer to eric's judgment here
anyway so in the game he played
something a little bit more boring
we went e3 everything we did here was by
the book
and now this idea of b4 how did i see
this well i saw the idea of knight a4
and i i was like wait this almost traps
the queen the queen is only one square
which is a5
can we take that square away
preemptively yes we can and bishop a
knight a4
i actually don't think that black is a
good move here because knight a4 is a
huge threat he has to go bishop d6
in order to create an escape score for
his queen but now we can simply take and
we can go bishop e2 and we're totally
fine here
now if he goes d4 a trick that i've
shown on several occasions what should
we capture the pawn with
tricky question
a6 maybe b5 and we make the queen side
explode
so
by the way this rosentrap has been
around for a while
i don't know um if it's been around for
a while
let me see i'm checking reference to see
if anybody has actually played no no
games found over the board that's
eric's novelty that's pretty impressive
stuff
so knight takes d4 is correct look at
this bishop it's hanging
if he takes we take the bishop if he
takes on e2 we don't take with this
knight we take with the other knight
in order to buttress the knight on d4
okay um hopefully that makes sense
so that that would have been a quick
example of um
of applying that kind of tactic in a
different position
um it was gm derrick's idea oh that's
awesome
i like derek a lot he's awesome great
streamer and he was the one who came up
with this so
kudos to derek that's still a pretty
impressive thing to come up with
something like this
but the pawn is pinned i hear people say
wait a second
witch pawn are you guys talking about it
i'm not sure what people are talking
about knight takes e2 is fine here
um which pawn is pinned here
yeah i think that was about a different
position i was about a different
position so anyways
um that's that the one you capture with
the knight
well it is oh it is pinned that is true
we can just castle
great observation ladies and gentlemen
the rook is undefended i didn't even see
that
so you can't actually cancel here or you
could go well you could go knight b5
uh and and that's that's pretty awesome
i love to see this i love to see people
applying
uh the kind of stuff we talk about and i
can just sense the improvement
great great work so of course 94 traps
the queen
any last questions before we go to the
next game i obviously i don't want to
spend
forever on these games there's one more
thing i wanted to make sorry to talk so
much
one more point i wanted to get out i
think it's important
when i do have something planned to
replace now when uh you play against
somebody who plays the gambit
uh you need to do some psychological
investigating because basically what you
need to tell yourself is okay
the guy that i'm playing wants to get a
very sharp position so that is also
partially why i play bishop f4 people
who play the england
they the last thing they want is a
is an end game particularly one down
upon so the psychological decisions you
make
have to reflect on what you think your
opponent
wants to do right what kind of position
does he want to get that's absolutely a
viable way of playing
if you're playing your friend you know
he loves sharp positions
getting into an end game is a very
viable strategy mark doretsky
had a whole lecture about this in one of
his books and it really made a big
impression on me
you're playing a real person you got to
know that person and you got to make
decisions partially on the basis of what
that person likes and dislikes you don't
want to take that too far
that is something you want to bear in
mind let's go with the next one
i know okay so we've been playing the
accelerated dragon
uh almost constantly okay let's play the
king's indian so that's what we've been
playing against d4
uh and and i've been introducing you
guys to some basic ideas in the king's
indian
let's see what what he does okay he
plays e3 so kind of a passive system
it's not bad
uh he plays basically the kali okay this
is really passive
and the kali against the king's indian
is actually not that great
because i'm not going to play d5 uh
what pawn break am i going to prepare
and those of you who play the king's
indian you have an unfair advantage here
but uh there's basically two main pawn
breaks in the sicilian one is to go c5
that's more of a banana sorry the king's
indian
one is to play a sicilian style with c5
but the other is to prepare e5
that is more in the spirit of the king's
indian first we have to go decent of
course of course first we need to
prepare it
now we need to prepare it by developing
the knight usually the knight goes to d7
and the king is indian but because he's
played it so passively
i'm going to allow myself developing the
knight to c6
and now we're going to play e5 now i
hear you guys think whoa
whoa whoa you're blundering upon he goes
b5 he attacks the knight and then he
takes the bomb but guess what
look at how white has developed his
pieces if the center opens up
all of these weaknesses he's created his
lack of development
that's going to make its presence felt
if you play the king's indian you got to
be ready to sacrifice on a moment's
notice
and so he correctly refrains from going
b5
now how should we continue uh what
should what do you guys think we should
do here should we go e4 and close up the
position attacking the knight
that would be a very sensible decision
but i don't want to do that quite yet
let's just
improve our position with rook to e8
just bringing the rook to a good square
and then we can i mean what you have to
understand about these openings is that
uh
they're not unlike other opening kings
indian is not something that you have to
play
in this sort of weird way uh all of the
rules apply okay he pins us
let's unpin ourselves with bishop to d7
uh so
rules of development always apply
so here we have a cool tactic
who sees it who sees the cool tactic
so the bishop is undefended how do i see
this what part of my brain
alerts me to this it's the bishop on b5
we've seen this time and time again the
bishops are out of standoff
which means that we need to consider
moves like knight takes d4 now there are
some moving parts here
if he takes on d7 the important thing is
that we take on f3
with check which gives us the time to
recapture on d7 now it's not that simple
he can take with the queen and then the
queen could take b7
but if he does that we'll be able to
check it out if he goes knight takes d4
we don't want to take the bishop because
that very same knight is going to
recapture it we want to take the knight
and if that situation arises we'll talk
about what to do after that that gets
very complicated
uh but we will work through the
complexities uh he is of course working
through them himself
okay he plays a bad move so he plays ed
which simply allows us to win upon
scot-free and this was his idea so this
is not a bad idea
but it's not going to work and let me
show you guys why
so 420 from blaze thank you we're going
to drop the bishop back first things
first
he's gonna take the pawn thinking okay
i've won back the pawn right
one two two attackers one defender
but what he hasn't anticipated this is
why i always harp on undefended pieces
look at this bishop he's the bishop
defended no it's not it's undefended
which means
the bishops are at a standoff it's the
same exact principle as knight takes d4
it's just wearing different clothes so
what can we do here with black there are
several ways to do the same thing
mm-hmm we can go knight to d7
and we open up that very same standoff
pawn can't move
and the pawn now has like a million
different attackers so we can just
recapture it with our knight or our pawn
and uh sort of the tactical skirmish is
over we are up a pawn
uh the game is the game is not over he
can go b5 and continue the pressure
so we're gonna have some pressure to
deal with here but if we deal with it
we're gonna
we're gonna be up a healthy pawn no need
to panic just bishop to d7 his pawns are
now
kind of weak as well and uh the e5 pawn
is nicely defended so knight f3 would be
a good move here
from his perspective and now i want to
make something
i want to make a move that a lot of
people are going to dislike
and that alone should be a big hand as
to what i'm about to play
what am i about to play they say never
make this move
close your eyes pray we're going to play
f6
why do i get away with this stuff why
did i play f6 here
i will explain that fully after the game
but the bottom line is
the bottom line is he doesn't have a
light squirt bishop and that's
in a single sentence why i allow myself
to do this
he has no piece to contest this diagonal
in the meantime
i have a bishop that i can put on e6 in
order to cover up the weakness created
by the move f6
what about the other bishop well that
other bishop is eventually going to find
employment through f8
okay so he takes the pawn i saw this uh
and and he's playing again very very
well but
i can also take a pawn so i calculated
this variation and concluded that
uh black is in good shape here it looks
like white has all this pressure but i
actually don't believe he does
we have a very nice move in this
position this queen on b7 is annoying
what are the weaknesses in white's
position let's take a step back for a
second the queen on b7 is annoying
observation one observation two the pawn
on b5 is kind of flimsy
can we combine both and make a very nice
queen retreat here
where should we put our queen in order
to excommunicate him yep queen b8 is
correct
now if he moves the queen he gives up b5
if he trades queens that plays right
into our hands
because that greatly reduces the
pressure that's currently being put in
our position
hope that makes sense we should take
with the rook and
uh now what should we do now we need to
once again take stock
of everything that's happening first and
foremost white's threats
so white wants to go rook to d7 here
but what's more important here is the
fact that the bishop is still undefended
and we can exploit this by undermining
the pawn on v5 which cannot move
should we play a6 or should we play c6
how do we go about the comparison here
so i'm actually going to think here
first
or should we make a third move now the
problem with c6 and the reason i'm
actually thinking
is that uh he might go we're gonna go c6
he's gonna go rook to d7 here which is
kind of annoying because he counter
attacks a7
a6 had a different flaw uh to that move
and i'll explain that after the game
uh the move a6 would have met with a
different annoying idea
but after rook d7 what's what's the
problem why can't i just take the free
panel because at the end of the day
he's going to take a7 and i don't want
to trade everything also the rook is
very active
but there is a way that we can
circumvent this we can take the pawn
and instead of taking with the bishop we
can take with the rook
that's the key move because we attack b2
okay this makes it kind of easy for us
we can just take a4 but yeah
wow he finds a very nice idea rook takes
safe
well he didn't see it but he could have
taken on a4 and counter-attacked our
bishop
now what is the order of operations here
priority number one is to defend the
pawn on a4 preferably
in a robust way let's go rook a priority
number two
this rook is his most annoying piece if
we can move that rook away from the
seventh rank
which i'm going to attempt to do here uh
we make it a lot easier for
us to supervise the promotion of this
pawn if there's a rook on c7 there's
possibility he gets another rook to see
to the seventh rank uh it's harder for
us to be single-minded
in the execution of our plan so
priority number one now that we've
defended the pawn is to get his rook
away from here
and we can actually do that by winning
some material as well what should we do
if you prioritize in the right way the
moves play themselves
we want to chase the rook away simple
bishop f8 and he's actually busted here
because he can't even move the rook
simple and winning
after we take that rook we're simply
going to push our a pawn
rooks go behind pass pawns it's not a
coincidence i played the move rook a8
i anticipated that later his bishop
would disappear and that would make that
rook
look very nice indeed okay so bishop
takes c7
and uh this is a good moment now a3
does it blunder the pawn yes doesn't
blunder it
but i don't really care if i was playing
a classical game i would have gone king
f7 here
uh but in the interest of sort of the
blitz game we can do this too it's it's
totally fine and uh even though he stops
the pawn temporarily
our next priority is to get rid of this
rook if we get rid of this rook
uh rook against bishop is is not a very
fair fight so where should we get this
rook to in order to get rid of the e1
rook
it's a very very simple maneuver i'm
sure you guys have seen this
many times before we simply dream up
the best square not rookie for careful
now rookie for
takes and his bishop still controls the
promotion square
so we'll win the bishop back but that's
not what we want we want to get the rook
to b1
so as i said yesterday be very careful
about
you know about trying to please the
crowd and and trying to play the fancy
move
try to play it simple instead uh you'll
you'll get rewarded in the end so rook
b4 is the move
a rookie 8 was fine yes yes yes this is
good
and let's play this as precisely as
possible
instead of promoting if he well he's
going to resign well
actually we can actually just promote um
i was going to try to actually take this
bishop out of the picture entirely so we
could make a whole queen
but but here if we go rookie eight then
then he's going to
to take a2 and we're gonna basically get
the same
exact thing so let's just freaking
promote and uh we're gonna be up a rook
this is an easy win and uh we're just
gonna go about training rooks here he
goes on time but the game is over anyway
okay this guy was good
uh he he resisted very very well so
kudos
and uh back to the opening so the way
that he played is very passive
knight c6 is relatively unusual and the
king's indian usually you go knight b to
d7 there's many many
many reasons for that uh one of which is
that normally white is the move d5
uh and that's exactly the question wap
lobster is asking but
here we simply take on d5 right that's
part of the downside of how passively
he's played this opening
so he goes b4 now if b5
and he takes our pawn look at how weak
this diagonal is we go knight d5
everything hangs and his position looks
terrible
so don't stop when you lose a pawn
calculate a little bit further okay
so rookie 8 improving the position of
the rook knight takes d4 is
the key tactic that basically won us the
game that started everything
uh and if he well first of all if he
takes here we take the knight then take
the bishop
if he takes here and that's what he
should have done
uh we can i would have just taken back
we could have considered playing dc
then he takes the rook but in this
position there is a key move
if he just moves the rook meekly then we
take with the knight
and look at this monster pawn we've got
a million pawns for the exchange
but what key move does white have in
this position
because two pieces are hanging bishop b3
uh in which
position yeah so bishop takes f7
desperado
bringing the king out then he goes after
the pawn and the landscape changes
because of how weak the king is and we
got more hype from run dmc for five
gifted subs thank you man
bishop b3 let's go to that point i don't
want to bore people to death boom boom
so 197 this high i'll explain during the
game oh my lance holy smokes
damn girl this is unbelievable 25 gifted
from chevy chaser holy smokes
can you believe this it just continues
on freaking believable 25 more from
chevy chaser has been
so supportive over the last couple days
i'm so happy to see that people are
enjoying this
and and this is amazing we are over 5200
subs
and it just goes on and on and on um
that's that's z486 with the tier one and
we are on to six thousand
ladies and gentlemen we're on cincinnati
uh
probably 300 plus plus the donations and
curious chimpanzee just adds on to it
with five more
tack him on damn girl five more subs
from curious chimp
i gotta take an espresso bean after that
uh
thank you so much this is amazing and it
continues the 140 am hype that's what
we're talking about
just give me a second guys
amazing thank you curious always
supportive as well
no no no you are okay
so can somebody alert me please to
bishop b3 where could he have gone
bishop b3 i'm just not sure
because he lost his bishop so he doesn't
have a light square bishop anymore
now f6 right hopefully it makes sense
um now that i've explained it and now
that you've seen how the game has gone
uh and the bottom line is that i'm
permanently solving the problem
of my pawn on e5 uh if we can compare
this you know what i would compare this
to guys
what i would compare this to is in my
first game
i know it looks different you see this
move d5
it's a move that leaves my opponent's
pieces in the dust
okay that's how i would refer to it uh
and and i'm doing exactly the same thing
here
where i'm leaving three of his pieces to
bite on granite
using that term again and leaving them
basically in the dust uh
and uh and and now all three of his
pieces are sort of doing nothing
now am i making concessions i absolutely
am i'm weakening my king
but again can't make an omelet without
breaking some eggs
okay so on to the end game now if we had
gone a6 instead of c6
he could have gone rook to c1 all of a
sudden counter-skewering my bishop
and at the end if i go bishop takes b5
he takes on c7 that's to his advantage
if i take with the rook and the same
thing happens and he can absolutely make
a draw here
okay so that's the reason i played c6 if
he goes rook c1 now
i play c takes p5 and that problem
solves itself
so people wanted to ask about bishop b3
why didn't i go here well remember
you could move the rope and defend the
pawn at the same time rook a1 when you
give a fork in your mind you need to ask
yourself can my opponent move
one of the pieces that are being forked
and defend the other and
if you ask yourself that directly it's
easier to find a move like rook a1
does this move look pretty no it looks
ugly as freaking
hell but sometimes like i said in the
last game you gotta play ugly moves okay
if you're in trouble
it's not about vanity and looking good
and you know combing your hair in front
of the mirror
it's all about the priorities and the
priority here is to defend the pawn
okay so c takes p5 and he found a nice
idea he could have played rook takes a
four counter attacking my bishop
i would have moved my bishop i'm still
up upon i still have good winning
chances
but he did a very good job here
navigating this until he went bishop a3
he sort of lost hope
and at this point the game is just over
we get his rook away from the seventh we
smoke it away from there
and we're up two pawns particularly this
pawn is the one that wins the game
um so why not bishop e3 so people are
still asking this but again
bishop b3 would not have been bad but it
would not have won the pawn
uh and it took me some time to see this
what about c6 then a6 instead of c6 then
take well c6
i mean oh i could have gone a6 yes i
probably should have
uh that was my original idea i missed to
be honest with you the move rook takes a
seven
i missed the move rook takes a four uh
so a6 probably would have been a better
idea
and he can't take either of these funds
i'm gonna win the pawn
okay
[Music]
you